16 Jahre ist es jetzt her, dass das letzte
Mal ein Überschallflugzeuge Passagiere super
schnell und luxuriös von A nach B gebracht
hatte.
Flugzeit New York London 3,5 Stunden.
Irre.
Jetzt werden Pläne für mögliche Nachfolger
der “Concorde” immer konkreter.
Schon 2035 könnte es Schätzungen zufolge
weltweit rund 2.000 dieser Super-Flieger geben.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es tägliche
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Genannt wurde sie auch “Donnervogel” oder
“Königin der Lüfte”: Die “Concorde”
brauchte nur 3,5 Stunden von London nach New
York.
Den Todesstoß versetzte ihr das Unglück
im Juli 2000.
Bei dem tragischen Absturz nach dem Start
am Pariser Flughafen kamen 113 Menschen ums
Leben: alle Passagiere sowie auch die Besatzung.
Das bedeutete das Ende des Projektes - wohl
überhaupt das umstrittenste der Luftfahrtgeschichte.
Denn von Anfang an war die Diskussion über
die “Concorde” groß.
Es ging um den Lärm der Triebwerke - und
so wurde es dem Überschalljet verboten, die
maximale Geschwindigkeit über Land zu fliegen.
Das war nur über dem Ozean erlaubt.
Ein weiteres Problem: Der sogenannte Überschallknall.
Ein verdammt lauter Knall, der bei dem Verdichtungsaustoß
entsteht, wenn das Flugzeug schneller fliegt
als der Schall in seiner Umgebung.
Die Schallgeschwindigkeit ist dabei von verschiedenen
Faktoren abhängig, wie beispielsweise der
Luftdichte und der Temperatur.
Das Verrückte dabei: Im Flugzeug selbst ist
der Knall nicht zu hören, weshalb den Passagieren
der “Concorde” immer in diesem “einzigartigen”
Moment Champagner ausgeschenkt wurde.
In einer Höhe von 11 Kilometern liegt die
Schallgeschwindigkeit beispielsweise bei rund
1060 Stundenkilometern.
Doch trotz der großen Probleme sind sich
Luftfahrtexperten sicher, dass die Überschall-Flugzeuge
schon bald ein Comeback feiern werden.
Und so tüfteln nicht nur große Firmen wie
beispielsweise “Lockheed Martin” und “Airbus”
an neuen Überschallfluggeräten für Interkontinentalreisen,
sondern auch viele Start-Ups.
Umwelt- und Verkehrsexperten vom International
Council on Clean Transportation (ICCT) haben
jetzt eine Studie veröffentlicht, nach der
bereits im Jahr 2035 etwa 2000 Überschallflugzeuge
unterwegs sein werden.
Und das tatsächlich an Flughäfen weltweit,
wie beispielsweise Dubai, London-Heathrow,
Frankfurt und New York.
Rund 160 Flughäfen werden in diesem Szenario
von den Überschallflugzeugen angesteuert,
teilweise mit mehr als 100 Starts und Landungen
pro Tag!
Bei der Entwicklung vorne mit dabei ist beispielsweise
“Boeing”: Der Konzern hatte im Sommer
2018 das Konzept für den sogenannten “Hypersonic-Jet”
vorgestellt.
Dieser soll mit fünffacher Schallgeschwindigkeit
fliegen.
In der Fachsprache auch als “Mach 5” bezeichnet.
Hierbei ist die Mach-Zahl eine dimensionslose
Angabe der Fluggeschwindigkeit.
Konkret zeigt sie das Verhältnis der Fluggeschwindigkeit
zur Schallgeschwindigkeit in der Umgebung.
Diese 5-fache Schallgeschwindigkeit des “Hypersonic-Jets”
wäre Wahnsinn, wie der Vergleich mit der
“Concorde” zeigt.
Sie schaffte damals maximal “Mach 2,2”.
Tatsächlich also eine Art Superflieger und
so wird die Entwicklung sicherlich auch noch
einige Jahre in Anspruch nehmen.
Bis zu 30 Jahren werden wir wohl noch darauf
warten müssen, so die Angaben von “Boeing”
selbst.
Anders dagegen sehen die Pläne des US-Startup
“Boom Technologies aus: Schon 2020 soll
die “Overture” in Betrieb gehen - wenn
auch nur mit Mach 2,2.
Zu den Investoren des Projekts gehören beispielsweise
Google, Airbnb und Dropbox.
Die Vision des Unternehmens: Passagiere für
rund 2.000 Euro in rund drei Stunden von London
nach New York bringen.
Bei der Concorde kostete dieser Luxus damals
übrigens umgerechnet 16.000 Euro.
Auch das Unternehmen “Airbus” ist beim
Thema “Überschallflugzeug” mit am Start
und entwickelt derzeit den Business-Jet AS2.
Schon 2023 sollen ein Erstflug stattfinden;
2025 könnten dann erst einmal bis zu zwölf
Passagiere abheben.
Später sollen dann deutlich mehr Passagiere
transportiert werden können.
Doch es gibt auch staatliche Bemühen, Überschallflugzeuge
wiederzubeleben.
Im Frühling 2018 machte die US-Weltraumbehörde
NASA Ernst und gab ein Überschallflugzeug
in Auftrag.
Und zwar wurde Rüstungskonzern Lockheed Martin
beauftragt, einen Prototyp des sogenannten
“X-Plane” zu entwerfen, zu bauen und zu
testen.
Etwa 200 Millionen Euro ist der NASA das wert.
Der Plan: X-Plane soll in 16.000 Kilometern
Höhe fliegen und zwar mit 1.500 Kilometern
pro Stunde.
Seine spezielle Bauform soll den lauten Knall
verhindern.
Und zwar indem die Schallwellen nicht miteinander
verschmelzen, sondern in kleine Stücke zerteilt
werden.
Die Bezeichnung des Designs: “Quit Supersonic
Technology” (QueSST).
Damit könnten die Jets direkt nach dem Start
in den Überschallmodus gehen.
Damit würde dann sogar die Reisezeit noch
einmal verkürzt werden!
Eine Miniatur-Version des neuen NASA-Überschall-Flugzeuges
wurde schon im Windkanal gestestet.
Im Jahr 2022 soll dann das endgültige Passagierflugzeug
mehrere Tests durchlaufen.
Für die Bevölkerung auf der Erde soll es
nach NASA-Angaben dann im besten Fall nicht
lauter sein soll als eine zufallende Auto-Tür
oder ein Donnergrollen.
Umweltexperten und -expertinnen sind dennoch
pessimistisch.
Sie warnen davor, dass viele Länder - darunter
auch Deutschland - mit regelmäßigen Überschallknalls
rechnen müssten.
Die Regionen rund um die Flughäfen seien
durch den extremen Lärm bei Start und Landung
dann unbewohnbar.
Hinzu kämen nach Angaben der aktuellen ICCT-Studie
100 Millionen Tonnen zusätzliches CO2, das
in die Erdatmosphäre gelangt.
Pures Gift für das Weltklima also!
Und so fordert die Non-Profit-Organisation,
dass sich die Unternehmen und Hersteller der
Überschallflugzeuge schon jetzt auf Umweltstandards
konzentrieren.
Könnten wir einen Weltraumaufzug bauen?
Klickt auf dieses Video.
Mega Spannendes Thema bei Doktor Whatson. Unbedingt
anschauen und abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!